Well, since we've been talking about distances a lot, we might as well find the
length of each side of this new black quadrilateral. This time, however, we're
just going to use these coordinates of the points that we know. So, what did we
use before? Well, we used the distance between the x-coordinates, and the
distance between the y-coordinates, squared each of those distances, added them
together, and then found the positive square root of that quantity. Interesting.
So, you can formalize this process for any two points, where one of the points
has the coordinates that I'll call x1 y1,. And the other point has coordinates
x2 and y2. I want to use these subscripts here because that let's me still show
that these two coordinates are in fact x-coordinates, and these ones are
y-coordinates, but, that they belong to different points. Now that we have this
handy formula, for the distance between any two points, we can calculate
distances just knowing coordinates. That means, we don't need to rely on our
picture anymore. Although, of course, it will be helpful in the future to go
back and reference it. We know that we can use this formula to calculate the
distance between any two points, so let's try it for each of the points that
creates the outline of our black quadrilateral, on the visual that I've now
conveniently taken away from you. The notation here that we're using is similar
to what we did before. MN, for example, is the distance between M and N, two
points on our list. You can consider this just two letters that form a single
variable. So, NP is the distance between N and P, PQ is the distance between P
and Q, and so on.